hey welcome to this week's YouTube video
I'm really excited because I get to sit
down and have a beer with a very famous
man whose runs one of the most popular
property channels
maybe even in the world okay keep going
yeah Kevin MacLeod real inspirational
great presenter great designer scream
writer and journalist so Kevin great to
have you on the show
thanks for coming down thank you for
that thank you for that big that's
lovely
so you are a very well-known presenter
and also a designer mm-hmm what do you
feel you're more well-known for which is
I never presented Oh presenting I mean
you know prior I mean I also developed a
very small development business but um I
had a manufacturing business for about
15 years and I know before that I did a
variety of things when you make a
television series like we go on the
telly yeah none of this matters because
people only remember you for that one
thing and because the reach is so huge
of course it's not in the thousands or
tens of thousands it's in the millions
that's why so I started out being
uncomfortable about the title of
television presenter and I thought that
should be called a broadcaster no I just
think I just describe myself as a piece
of tell you fluff because that's really
the job at being the regimental mascot
you know I just have to look pretty good
so yeah presenting or designing which
one money pay I'd be unemployable
I am unemployable in any other
discipline so that's it and then I I
can't even contemplate giving up making
television programs I what I suppose I
am responsible for is that thing called
content I can edit a bit and I can film
a bit with my phone and I can you know
cut sound and what have ya get I I've
got the basic yeah but really my my my
job is in front of the camera and it's
it's an interpreter to job it's about
telling stories really yeah
storyteller I mean I know you background
you went to university it used to be
history of art and history of architects
I'm like what was what was not the
biggest thing that you learned through
those studies there served you really
well today still oh gosh you know I
think probably the great value for me of
that education was developing some
critical faculties just being able to
understand
what proper researchers understand what
it takes to write something perhaps and
to learn that it isn't good enough even
for a university tutor it isn't good
enough just to write in a style or
language which is super factual it isn't
good enough simply to put the facts on
the piece of paper and then your
interpretation whatever it is it really
matters to tell a story it really
matters to catch somebody's imagination
it doesn't matter if they're a a client
of yours it doesn't matter if they're a
reader my daughter who's a journalist
and I remember having this conversation
with her because she was faced with this
distinction between following an
academic career or or going into
journalism and we had this conversation
precisely about this area which is when
you write for a magazine you are you're
selling something you know your your
your awakening somebody's imagination
when you write a script when you write a
column or or even just a description in
a magazine or a brochure it you're
having to convey ideas hopefully in a
fresh way which are going to spark
ignite people's responsiveness it's
gonna wake something up in here yeah and
that to me is it's what my job is all
about whether it's writing a thousand
words for a column or a 100 word
description for the exhibition at the
NEC for a green hero or whether it's
writing a script which is a bit more
like writing a tabloid newspaper because
you have to kind of come dense
everything down to a little piece of
commentary that last four and a half
seconds or 15 seconds or something so
it's what I think that's probably what I
learned and being the great storyteller
I mean you get people very excited about
design and property in general how many
people do you think you've inspired to
go and do their own design or to go
install that house to get people playing
a lot a tempo I mean it's funny this
because no of course with social media
and with your site yeah you can yo thank
you thanks for being a subscriber
delighted I hope your
return the favor when I finally get my
YouTube channel up and running um but
the point about that is you have the
numbers they're written beneath saying
telling you how many subscribers how
many you know on your Twitter feed you
can tell you how many people are
following you yeah they may not be
reading you but those are subscribers
whereas with television how many views
did you get last night well actually the
viewing audience and television is
calculated based on I can you tell you
about 200 households which have got
these little boxes fidgets it backs up
their televisions and it tells the audit
Bureau circulation whenever it is just
how many people of that small sample
representative of the entire nation how
many people watched that program that
night well I can tell you that Grand
Designs might get 1.8 to 2.2 million
people but actually in the next hour
when it's repeated that will go up to
2.5 or 2.6 million and actually over the
next three days it'll go up to three to
three and a half million yeah and that
doesn't take into account then further
watches yeah the people click on me know
by our website or by whatever channel so
it's really hard to establish these days
who's watching yeah how many people are
watching and how you activate your
figures it's very interesting too that
Netflix who brought ground designs never
publish their fingers and what they do
is they tell you how many subscribers
they have worldwide or in a particular
territory they'll tell you how many
people subscribe to Netflix and
therefore how many people that product
is open to I'm sure that they're able to
determine for example how many people
watch those clicks I will never know
that they never tell you all that
happens is you either get we commission
or you don't
yes I guess what you do know though is I
mean you get stopped in the street or
not like but yes what do people normally
swim it when they stop you in the street
what do people usually say to you I love
that program I really love that one you
did when you went to that garden back
cutting stuff yeah or yeah I love your
program when you're coming back I
particularly like the one you did where
you did you did some Italian cooking
whatever it is yeah you know they
confuse you with other people I have
been Monty Don and I have been George
Clark quite a lot and I am mistaken for
one or two other people I'd say this
after 20 years of doing it people now
generally do recognize Who I am the
coolest thing is when I get people in
elevators coming up to me for only
searches and saying I started watching
Grand Designs when I was ten or eight or
twelve with my parents
yeah and I really got into it and I know
not attacked that yes that gives me
goose bumps is that why you do this it's
not why I do it
no but it's it suddenly marks the time
yeah and it also reminds me that the
best thing television can do is get
people to think it's a really hard
ambition because most people watch
television and just simply let it sort
of wash over them yeah
it's what's called the water cooler
effect you know do they go to work the
next day do they talk to their mates
their colleagues about what they saw
last night it happens less than this
because people watch different platforms
at different times
viewing is far more selective but I'm
I'm pleased to say that we still get a
good heartland of solid support in the
millions of people who do watch it when
it is broker so yeah in that sense it's
it's living what the broadcasters called
event television you know they people to
stay in and watch Grand Designs that
evening when that series comes down so I
love it when people say to me you know I
watched that I saw that made me think I
went away
I've now built a house or I'm thinking
of doing it with my whatever or I became
an architect or I want to become an
architect yeah it's a great field you
know it's kind of so exciting because
all I do is just push stuff out there
yeah drink beer and try and find in
every day the energy the enthusiasm the
kind of the sort of the inspiration if
you like and what people are doing in
the real world and if it's a great
quality then I want to celebrate that
and push it Nick you just you're pushing
into a little black tube called a camera
and you're hoping that he's gonna come
out the other end and have an effect any
when people do respond it is the it's
the most one you said that that's not
the strongest reason why what is the
strongest reason why you do we do oh I'm
quite driven yeah I'm quite driven and I
am driven to to celebrate I if all I did
was make documentaries about
architecture for Guardian readers
I don't think I'm I mean I could feel
perhaps intellectually satisfied but I
don't think I'd feel comfortable I I'm
quite a democratizer I believe in can't
try to deliver the best possible quality
to the largest possible audience yeah
and in that sense we've been designed I
sort of found my niche I think so that
that's a big driver do you see yourself
more as an educator or an inspire or an
entertainer
yeah all of those actually and it's
important to be all of those if you are
an educator you will end up making
programs to the Open University if
you're trying to inspire people the
danger is you become a generalist and
you end up working across a whole
variety of disciplines and John Russell
so text my area is architecture and
design therefore that is where I want to
mmm that's what I want to celebrate and
I'm not happy celebrating rubbish yeah
I'm not happy celebrating the mediocre I
want to celebrate and show good stuff
and it's you know sometimes we end up
with slightly mediocre projects you
don't know how they're gonna turn out we
take a punt it doesn't quite work
sometimes we end up with this great
architecture and that's when I can
really you know let go and sometimes we
end up with buildings which most of us
might look at and think get better this
yeah that's odd
that's weird but actually it fits a
niche it has a place a role within what
is that big sense architecture what is
what the idea of home is so from there
gives me an opportunity to celebrate the
quirky unusual and you've been on quite
a few different shows I mean grand
design is the one that they of course
that's your show that your big baby that
you famous for but outside of that
what's been the most interesting show
that you feel you've been on the one you
enjoyed most Wow and well I really did
enjoy enjoy I really I find it very
satisfying to make the two programs
about Dara V in India well we spent two
weeks I spent two weeks in a slum
I was out in sweeties but I found it
enormous ly inspiring
living among a million people in a
square mile and understanding how that
community worked and what made community
in place and I learned a great deal from
it and that series for me was exciting
this by and not least actually and this
is the educator right not least because
I've met so many geography human
geography teachers and schools who've
said we use that series to show that's
crippling sick bombs yeah you know as an
education tool so that's exciting when
you feel actually it's gone beyond just
the original telly transmission and it's
just as something so that was meaningful
but I enjoy I enjoy a lot of it I
enjoyed like to shed series what you
should series I'm a very much enjoyed
making the Grand Tour which was a bit of
an indulgence for me
so Grand Designs yeah how did that come
into fruition I mean I know you've been
doing that for 20 21 years now we're all
well done because this year you see we
celebrate our 20th anniversary but well
it's 20 it's technically 22 since we
started because now we're in the end of
this year so um yeah I think we started
in 97 a toy talk to me about the
fruition of that and and how how that
came into being and how you got into in
the first place I mean it television is
the world of television is really weird
because you you you you you you pitch an
idea to a channel or to a production
company and the production company kind
of said reap pitches it to the channel
tries to make it their own it's all
about who's gonna get the royalties yeah
and you hope then it's gonna get
commissioned and then you after you got
commissioned you know you're your
wildest dreams of it would get
recommissioned as a second series so we
did the first series thinking we'll see
what happens you know probably nothing
we made that and then they said that it
was a long period but it's nothing
we'll go off and try to find something
else to do but they did read and then we
got to series two or three and they said
yeah we commissioned two series ahead
and that's suddenly made a world of
difference because you've moved from
being a production company with a an
office that you assemble quickly from
people who just have to be there to
actually being a proper office yeah
which is permanently staffed and that
not heard of it Terry it doesn't happen
in many realms of television so for
example our production coordinator who
makes the entire series possible amy has
been with us since 2005 Helen our
production managers been with us since
2001 I think that's a long time to it to
be in any job for anybody
yeah and that gives it a tremendous
maturity our directors come and go
because we we chew em up and spit
America but bringing a dry and to be
frank it's also a job you can burn out
on directing if you're not careful
because it's very intense but my current
producer John Donne Lonsdale has been
produced on the shoots for what seven
years now so it's we're a big team and I
count a lot of them as friends and you
I've worked with the same cameraman Tony
at well for 20 years and I've worked the
directors for actually longer so on and
off so yeah it's it's a really small
band of people yeah and the quality of
what you see is down to the so shared
beliefs and D and you know lots of
evenings spent in the pub discussing
talking about what we're trying to do
yeah how we might evolve it what matters
how to that we've been you know then and
trying to sort of retain maintain polish
and burnish all the values that your
series stands up for a while at the same
time so try to involve it in technical
terms you know with the new kit that
we're able to you know use these days
different camera
so it's it's it's it's a huge
collaboration so talk to me a bit about
design then so you you still be used to
the architect you then worked in the
theater as I read I trained as a surgeon
decided out was that it was exciting it
was very theatrical and as much as you
know in designing costumes and sets of
lighting you're designing entire worlds
it's what architects do in fact and and
I got into it because I like the theater
and I like the artifice of it I like the
fact that it was a separate world away
from text that counts and you know
difficulties of shopping and you know
and the dentist and yeah it was just
this magical miniature world and
miniature for me because there's a
theatre designer he spent a lot of time
model making and as a kid I've been huge
about my time making models yeah an
architect's spend a huge amount of their
time generally as kids making models
here playing with train sets and the
idea of tried to sort of make these
making these worlds which might or might
not impact on the eventual real world
but which in as a model it's hard to
express this but as a model it's in a
pure state so if you make a model of a
housing scheme or of a beautiful
building
it will never go green with mould you
know and damp it will never suffer the
graffiti or problems of over parking you
know it's a bit of perfect vision of
what I think many architects go into
that world for that because that's what
sort of drives to me to sort of creative
process mmm design which we all do we're
all capable of it just takes us quite a
lot longer and architects and
professional designers are much faster
much more skilled experience have a much
wider range of tools and techniques yeah
they can use but nevertheless their
drive is to make the world in our image
in a human image you know to create a
man-made world which should serve
mankind should serve us yeah everything
we see is designed pretty much
of course every touch home would pick up
and has been designed yeah and of course
there is
there's be true vien principles that
contributes right about in the third
century BC still held true which are
that the any well-made object should be
it should be well made it should be more
constructive it should be solid and
durable it should also be very easy to
use you know to actually kind of make
living in life and using it actually a
pleasure yes and it should also be an
object of delight in the same way and
and I think those principles of designs
still held true but to those I would
also add the value of sustainability
because I think we've now moved to a
place where we understand that every
time we make you know an object that
that object you know has not just a
commercial value but an environmental
value an impact it's using resources
yeah and we've got to make sure that we
got enough of those there for future
generations yeah I think convenience
designed to be convenient is something
that now more than I went went online my
new house there's toilets pretty much
you pretty much every room I know you
think we've gone a bit Twitter a bit
toilet mat but it doesn't understand
that but it's competing it now so what
how convenient do you need to toilet to
be I mean oh look I've got a sofa it
turns into a toilet look my car seat
turns into a toilet yeah look my kitchen
turns into a toilet back in probably
when you and my age
uhuhu to go to the toilet in your own
house yes we had one toilet between five
of us but you learn to keep it in and
you learn and you learn to kind of
stagger you know okay so I'm not
suggesting that a family of five should
have one toilet what I'm just suggesting
it's very simple that if the five people
living in a house perhaps fewer than
five toilets is appropriate more than
five toilets is you know that is why do
you think we've gone is do you think
it's convenient you think we're just
going crazy he's nuts how when you're
building
I mean trends often move faster than
construction yeah how do you plan for
that or pin you know I don't know you
can know REM koolhaas a Dutch architect
says that you know
there's no point trying to be
fashionable in architecture because it
takes so long yeah you know by the time
you've got for your planning and you've
got it built yeah anything that was
fashionable the time is no longer it's
no longer with the castle yeah it's
probably gonna be a couple of years
before it's completely done but it's a
case of how do we look at what's in
trend right now or do we just do just do
what well I mean with a castle
I just repair it that's the main thing
right and that's what you're doing isn't
you're repairing and trying to sort of
in a way not reinvent it would just kind
of all but somehow elevate its story its
narrative and I always like projects
which are repair projects where you
could see the interventions you can see
what's done in the 21st century you can
see what was done the 1950s and you
actually just show it just leave it and
you tidy it up a little bit but not too
much and as it was well I think we did
we do attend to over tidy stuff I think
we tend I think ambiguity in the built
world is a really good thing
what makes old castles romantic is when
the IV's is hanging off a little bit of
crumbling Rock don't work right when
somebody comes along and tied is it all
up and repoint signal yeah what about
the inside well I think equally on the
inside if you've got a beautiful painted
eighteenth-century door it's you know
what in a way why would just the sake of
a few Nicks why would you repaint it if
it's exquisite and you love it yeah if
there are bits that you love which speak
of the story and the history of it
why would you repaint why would you tidy
them up too much when actually what
they're telling you is how their
Billings being used you know where the
story is and so for me it comes back to
narrative it comes back to the idea of
our buildings tell their stories and
what makes inspring alive and what made
you buy in the first place you know Kay
yes always that romantic yeah notion
isn't it that lovely scent of attention
there it is it's just amore Wow I mean I
bought it as an investment ultimately I
wanted to I wanted to look great when
you're designing for a home to live in
yeah what what are the differences is
there a whole different set of rules
because if I'm buying a house to live in
and I'm buying houses mean back yeah I
have a different set of rules what about
I've lived in I'd lived in old buildings
yeah but I've nearly always demanded
that I have a brand new sofa
do you know me I don't feel the need to
furnish the old building with an ancient
Savior that's uncomfortable yeah what
matters to me is sitting on a sofa being
able to rest my head fall asleep and
feel super comfy as I might doing a bed
yeah I don't think that there's a
necessity to have to furnish a building
and somehow in accordance with where
it's from or how old it is there are
various kind of rules of thumb you can
add ah but one of them is everything
which is part of the building attached
to the walls you know is overtime but
when you come to put in the lights which
is what you do there do you do go out
and buy you know kind of reproduction
19th century or there's no such thing as
a 16th century light switch so what you
know how do you do that within our
building and the answer is you just do
it with some delicacy and some respect
yeah and and when it comes to furnishing
well then actually that's as much about
the human being as it is about the story
of the building so it's a tough one and
I think it actually what it really needs
is is just a little bit of sensitivity
and also and you'll know this sort of
natural kind of an energy a drive you
know you've got a vision for that place
and in a sense what you have to do is to
follow that vision yeah it may not be my
vision or so much they'll see it may not
be to my taste but if I walk into that
building that you're repairing and
redoing what I'm actually looking for
what I'm looking for what I'm looking
for is narrative I'm looking for I'm
looking to understand the building yeah
to not see it too scrubbed up in to tidy
I don't care about the blinking sofa I
don't care about your washing machine or
what brand of careful you or your
standard lamps or your beds I don't
really care about the light switches
because they they're just a plate they
can be taken off and replaced yeah what
I do care passionately about is the
fabric of the building and an
eight-story and it's kind of how it's
been revived and no that's really helped
you know how you respect that because
for sure you know to me
what I can't mention question 20 if you
advising your 20 year old self three
pieces of a best advice boo what would
you say oh my god
I think I'd I'd say pace yourself yeah
because you know if you're lucky life is
long and I want to carry on doing what
I'm doing for another thirty years so
I'll take some 90 so you'll still be
doing Grand Designs but I don't know if
they commissioned it back in imagine a
baby I probably need a team help getting
around building sites but um so I think
I'd say pace yourself yeah and I would
also I think I've come to realize that
I'm a better communicator than I am
designed it I mean I think I've made
more success in my life out of writing
and talking about things and celebrating
other people's work I'd learn that soon
I think that would have helped outside
of designing what you want to be most
remembered for um doesn't matter none of
that matters don't I want to be
remembered by my children I want to I
want to be remembered by the people that
means something to me
yeah I don't know my customers there's a
job it's a great thing about doing an
exhibition say at the NEC yeah which
where we are this week five days is I
get to meet a hundred thousand customers
yeah I don't normally get to see or
understand you know they're just it's
just a number in that black tube and
speaking to three million or four
million people
it's an incomprehensible number and I
can't possibly hope to kind of
understand who they are yeah or even
what my value is to them therefore it
would be inappropriate for me to ask
them to remember me when I'm just a bit
of flickering the television screen no I
mean no no so but the point is I don't
know yeah the answer to that question I
don't know what I mean to them so the
only thing I matters the only thing
matters to me is that for some time
after that my kids and you know if they
have children their children yeah and my
friends you know
left when I go didn't any anything else
really matters the rest of it is all
hubris the rest of it is all tell you
fluff nonsense isn't it what's so sure
but I understand your point listen what
you're most excited about at the moment
I know you've got this fantastic grand
grand design going on at the moment live
what are you just a little bit about
that yes so this week this week I am
mainly standing on stage declared as I
slide my gear is all is basically
organized around these two events which
is London's excel you know early May and
then at the end I'd like to do is to say
hello to all those people who turn up
who I already do know people who who
bleed before who have I spoken to all so
many exhibitors and specifically a lot
of the grand designers to be filmed over
the years who coming on stage with me
and we talk in front of an audience
about yeah you know their projects and
where their life has taken them so I
mean it's a good it's a big social
Jamboree it's kind of it's it's so crap
watching this they're mostly in property
what should be the number one reason why
they should attend the event Oh lots of
reasons I mean first of all the
exhibition is divided into lots of
different areas if you're interested as
a homeowner yeah there's every reason to
come because there's everything from you
know carpet tiles to stoves to lab stuff
kitchen knives and placemats
Oh placemats I'm also bought a table I
bought a dress as well from a crumb and
both were from craftsman makers so
they're not on the history that people
you've got workshops and you know
factories where have you in middle of
nowhere and they come to Grand Designs
like to exhibit because there's no
welcome to go and because their stuff is
only see it on the internet when you
touch something begin to really
appreciate and understand its quality
yeah and if you go to an exhibition you
can do that I love you go did you only
see you can do that you cannot do that
on the Internet yeah very true how you
get there by going on a train or a bus
or in your car
you go to I'm sending my best toast of
London boys www-what grand designs
live.com love that yeah it's been really
good getting to know ya and I look for
to lunchtime and you Cheers yeah yeah
yeah great measures of kiss thank you
[Music]